what's up everyone it's Warren and we
just got brand-new footage for Avengers
in game in the TV spot that they played
during the Superbowl commercial and it
was awesome and it was all entirely new
footage so I'm going to break some
scenes down in this video for you as
well as another breakdown video later on
this week and also I'm starting a new
giveaway today with the launch of the
new Avengers in game footage giving away
five imax tickets to go see Avengers in
game the night it comes out all you have
to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel like the video comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite character that can be a hero or
a villain and let me know why they're
your favorite so to start off in the
very first second of this trailer one
second it shows all of the characters
who got dusted right before it shows the
logo getting dusted if you slow it down
you can see all of them but if you blink
you'll miss it so we go to the first
scene that shows Steve talking and he's
with a group and there's a poster that
says where do we go now that they're
gone
this could be an old poster for a
meeting for people who have lost people
in the past before the snap it could be
unrelated to the snap but if it is
referring to the ones that were lost
because of the decimation that means
that some time has passed since where
they are now in this trailer and the
decimation which would line up with a
rumor that was happening about Avengers
endgame not too long ago that stated
avengers endgame will actually take
place a few years into the future after
the snap but the big thing here is Steve
Rogers saying some people move on but
not us this is clearly implying that he
tends to undo the snap somehow he may
not know what it is at this point in
that footage that we saw but he intends
to figure out a way to undo the snap no
matter what and then we get this awesome
scene with Tony Stark and nebula and
they're tinkering around with a Benatar
clearly they're trying to figure out
some way to get the ship working to get
them home tony is a genius he knows
mechanics he built all of his Iron Man
suits surely he can figure out a way to
get the benatar working to get him home
nebula is pretty smart herself and Tony
can tell her what to do for the most
part as well but it seems like they're
working pretty quick
we hear and that's probably just for
Tony's sake because nebula isn't really
at jeopardy he or she can survive in
outer space and she doesn't really need
food and water because she's basically a
machine so that just shows that nebula
is doing all that she can't for Tony so
she can try to save him and speaking of
which in the next scene we see some of
the Avengers walking outside of the
Avengers facility looking up into the
sky
could this be Tony Stark and nebula
returning to earth
remember what Marvel Studios is
President Kevin Feige said about the
footage that we're going to see up until
the movie he said that we're only going
to see about the first 15 to 20 minutes
in any footage or trailer that we see
before the movie comes out so if Tony
Stark and nebula make their way back to
Earth in the first 15 to 20 minutes this
may be the scene that we're seen because
obviously Tony is not going to spend the
whole entire movie floating around
adrift in space we then go to rocket who
was wearing his original guardians of
the galaxy clothing from the comics the
Russo brothers have said they draw
inspiration from the comics this is
clearly one thing that they took and put
in the movie so the next really
important scene is Ant Man and war
machine and the main thing here is ant
man's back so in the first Avengers
in-game teaser trailer that we got and
we saw the video recording of Ant Man at
the Avengers facility that could have
been in real time and not actually in
the past but it's clear that Ant Man is
back he's obviously there at the
Avengers facility which means that he's
going to tell them about what happened
to him and he's going to explain a time
vortex to the rest of the Avengers and
then we have this scene with Thor and it
looks like to me that he is in one of
two places one is Wakanda and two is on
Titan two in Thanos his Hut which if
that is true that means he went
searching for Thanos we see Stormbreaker
in his hand we know Stormbreaker has the
power to summon the Bifrost
so maybe Thor went off looking for
Thanos then we have this scene of
Hawkeye who is still Hawkeye in the
Avengers in game first teaser trailer
that we got he was Ronan so this is
clearly footage from before he becomes
Ronan or after he's clearly underground
somewhere searching for something
possibly but it's obvious that we're
going to see Hawkeye in the movie not
just Ronan and then we have Captain
America's shield of our
seen a lot of people saying that this is
actually Hawkeye holding captain shield
it's not if you look at his gloves and
his belt in the background it's
definitely Captain America so we finally
see him get a shield back in Avengers
end game and that means that Tony might
have given him a shield back himself
because we know Tony had captain shield
and Steve has already been back to the
Avengers facility and Avengers infinity
war and the shield clearly wasn't lying
around somewhere because he never had it
in the movie so Tony's probably the one
that gave him a shield back and then we
have this last scene of all the
remaining Avengers with the exception of
Tony Stark and nebula walking to prepare
for a mission
as we can see cap is leading them Thor's
behind him got Natasha behind him then
rocket Scott Rhodey and Bruce so it
doesn't seem like Tony and nebula are
back yet but ant-man is back and it
seems like they have a clear mission at
this point which means that it clearly
involves the quantum realm probably time
travel again it's all but confirmed but
the return of ant-man coming back to the
Avengers facility gives them a new hope
and a new plan and that's it for all the
new scenes of The Avengers in game Super
Bowl TV spot again it was awesome and
I'll do a more in-depth breakdown later
on this week but let me know what you
thought about this awesome TV spot that
aired during the Super Bowl let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
and again don't forget to subscribe
comment down below and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything related to Marvel
and Avengers in game as always thank you
all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]